[Music]
new at 11 rebounding from the pandemic
shutdown and the wedding industry is
booming in fact it's the biggest year
we've seen for vegas weddings since
2015. sasha loftus attended an event
tonight that was all about weddings and
she joins us live with the very latest
brian the couples we spoke with can't
wait to tie the knot here in las vegas
now things were tough last year with the
covid 19 shutdowns but the wedding
industry is back with a vengeance and a
new brand honestly i knew on our first
date that he was the one it's easy to
see samantha michaels and colby wood are
very much in love
newly engaged they can't wait to walk
down the aisle here in las vegas if
we're going to do it might as well do it
right they're one of many couples tying
the knot locally and for the wedding
capital of the world things aren't
looking up we kept love alive in las
vegas clark county held its fifth annual
state of the industry event wednesday to
celebrate the most marriage licenses
they've seen in about 20 years despite
kovid
people want to get married and they
really want to
share their lives together pandemic
shutdowns brought a slight slump last
year but chapel of the flowers ceo
donnie korestic says pent-up demand and
a focus on forever has made all the
difference it's not the hangover it's
not you know the raunchy weddings these
are nice formal weddings from people all
over the world and if you ask samantha
and colby their special day will
celebrate their true devotion to each
other every time i listen to the song
that i'm going to walk down the aisle to
i cry while experiencing everything in
this city that makes matrimony more than
memorable
clark county is also expected to mark
its 5 millionth marriage license later
this year they'll of course be a huge
celebration that goes along with that
now those here with chapel of the
flowers say as international travel
starts to pick up again next year they
expect to see an even higher uptick in
marriage numbers here locally reporting
live in las vegas tonight sasha loftis 8
news now